The answer is that the first one
is false and the rest are true.
The first one is false because
a a b a is not from sigma star,
it's from gamma star.
In the order here of say,
gamma star and sigma star matters.
If we were to reverse these,
then it would be in the language.
b is in sigma star b.
Because the empty string
is in sigma star.
And we can concatenate that with b,
to get b.
Sigma union gamma is the set
of strings 0, 1, a, and b.
So applying star to that gives us
all strings over all those symbols
including this one here.
And finally, because the empty
string is not in gamma plus,
it is in the complement of gamma plus.
So this statement is true as well.